[Music]
on this sunday night
looking back while fighting forward
americans remember a civil rights giant
as fresh protests over racial injustice
erupt across the country
sparking clashes with federal agents
that's
not american plus entering the bubble
nhl players move into their new canadian
hub cities and get a first look at the
pandemic precautions
and a canadian celebrity offers a cash
reward
for a priceless teddy bear
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple good evening and thank you
for joining us
on the same day americans are
memorializing one of the most important
figures in the civil rights movement
police are cracking down on protests in
several american cities
in a moment we will take you to the
scene of congressman john lewis's final
crossing
over the infamous bridge in alabama the
site of what became known as bloody
sunday
but first to the fierce face-offs across
the u.s
as demonstrators clash with police
president donald trump's decision to
deploy heavily armed federal agents to
quell the protests
appears to be having the opposite effect
jennifer johnson has our top story from
washington
unrest in portland oregon and seattle
washington overnight
as protesters set fires and destroyed
property the black lives matter march in
seattle started peacefully
but turned violent as demonstrators
targeted the king county youth detention
center
some used hammers to shatter workers
cars
they slashed all four of my tires they
broke my back window out
you know i just i just gotta work i want
to go home
police and federal agents use pepper
spray and tear gas against the
demonstrators
shots rang out people can be heard
screaming in the streets
in portland there have been daily
protests against police brutality for
two months
after the death of george floyd in
minneapolis things had started to quiet
down
until u.s president donald trump
deployed federal agents to the city july
4th
it's horrible being tear gassed is
horrible
it's painful they mean it to be painful
president trump
claimed he sent the federal agents to
these democrat dominated cities
to maintain calm and protect the federal
courthouse building in portland
but their heavy-handed tactics have led
to solidarity protests across the
country
no you can't have a call no you can't
have a lawyer we're just going to
terrorize you terrify you
intimidate the crowd so you don't come
out and protest that's
not american white house officials say
federal agents aren't leaving portland
until these demonstrations calm down
we have federal agents there that are
protecting a courthouse that actually
have
has not only been vandalized but they're
trying to burn it down
in many places tensions are reaching the
boiling point protesters wanting an end
to racial injustice
opponents growing weary of the chaos in
austin one protester was shot to death
in colorado this car barreled through a
group of demonstrators
protests turned violent in richmond
virginia too police in riot gear fired
tear gas and rubber bullets to break up
the crowd
anger and frustration still spilling out
onto america's streets
long after floyd's death was seen by the
world
jennifer johnson global news washington
and those demonstrations are drawing
plenty of comparisons to protests
five decades ago back in march 1965 what
became known as bloody sunday marked a
turning point in the civil rights
movement
well today one of its leaders john lewis
was memorialized
and his funeral procession passed over
the very same bridge
where a peaceful march met a violent
police crackdown
lewis was nearly killed when a state
trooper cracked open his skull with a
billy club
and as mike armstrong explains that
image and lewis bravery
helped to spark a racial reckoning
it has been called the final crossing
a civil rights legend john lewis carried
one last time
across the bridge where he was almost
killed
on that day 55 years ago it was a police
officer's billy club that
cracked lewis skull on this day alabama
state troopers lifted their hands
to salute
the screams are one of the things that
stand out when the stories of that day
are told
march 7 1965 men
and women marching for voting rights
were met by police
and civilians armed with clubs 67
marchers were injured about a quarter of
them had to be hospitalized
that included one of the leaders john
lewis
what happened on this bridge wasn't the
only time he was beaten
getting into what lewis called good
trouble put him in danger often
in one incident the man who beat him was
identified but lewis refused to press
charges he said the struggle wasn't
against one man
but against the system that produced
that man
well one of lewis's accomplishments was
being part of the leadership that
kept that struggle alive after another
of its leaders
was killed we we couldn't let
the assassination of dr king stopped the
movement
lewis would call this bridge hallowed
ground and return
often for the 50th anniversary in 2015
he walked across with u.s
president barack obama even in march of
this year he took part in the
anniversary while battling stage four
pancreatic cancer
now the bridge crossing is only one in a
week of tributes and ceremonies
lewis body will be moved to washington
for monday and tuesday then
to georgia his funerals in atlanta
thursday but
another tribute may come later that
bridge he crossed is named after edmund
pettus a confederate general from the
civil war
who was also a grand dragon of the klu
klux klan there is a
movement growing to rename it after john
lewis
mike armstrong global news
and back here at home now where canada's
first black
national news anchor has died george
elroy boyd passed away at a montreal
hospice on july 7th but his death was
only made public this weekend
boyd made history as one of the original
anchors on cbc news world he was named
co-host of the morning show on the
24-hour news channel in 1992
the halifax native later left
broadcasting to pursue his first love
writing he went on to write for radio
television and
theater boyd was 68.
and one of the world's most beloved
movie stars two-time oscar winner olivia
de havilland has died
the actress is best known for her role
in the 1939 film
gone with the wind but she's also being
remembered for taking on
hollywood winning a major court case
that imposed a seven-year limit on
studio contracts
de havilland died at her home in paris
she was 104
and four-time stanley cup winner eddie
shack has also died
shaq was one of the league's most
colorful players both on and off the ice
he was known for his bruising style
distinctive skating gait
and larger-than-life personality the
ontario native won
four stanley cups with the toronto maple
leafs including the franchise's last
victory in 1967
shaq was 83. and staying with hockey now
it is a big day for the nhl players and
staff from 24
teams all entered their bubbles in
toronto and edmonton
they will be back on the ice later this
week for the restart
of the stanley cup playoffs canadians
are excited for hockey to resume but as
mike lucator explains
there are also significant public health
risks at play
how secure is the nhl bubble you
couldn't even catch a glimpse of players
arriving at one of their toronto hotels
sunday
fences fit for an international summit
keep nhlers away from fans but yogida
sharma and her son
are still excited this is giving us a
way of hope that they are there right so
it's giving us a
hope that we'll be soon having the
session having the league started
if you wanted to connect with your
favorite player you had to be on social
media to see teams making the journey
to the two bubble cities toronto and
edmonton
the montreal canadiens held a virtual
send-off party for
fans while vegas's william carlson
had more of a private goodbye with his
pooch
players could be away from home for up
to two months so it's no surprise
they've packed everything
from guitars to video game consoles a
lot of video games and
netflix and face timing with with my dog
there have been jokes about playing in a
bubble this was posted by habs forward
max domi
but breaching it is serious as some nba
players have been forced to quarantine
for 10 days after leaving and returning
the nhl won't be allowing that leaving
the bubble
is is just not something that we can
tolerate
everybody's used terrific judgment to
this point
and i know that we can count on
everybody going forward
now in edmonton the famous replica of
the stanley cup is being polished
outside a local sports store while
members of the nashville predators
enter their bubble having 12 teams in
each hockey hungry city could attract
autograph seekers
that's likely why the security fences
have been installed
infectious disease experts want fans to
remember that just because hockey
is back doesn't mean kovid 19 is gone
we shouldn't be congregating together
even if that means to see your favorite
hockey player so
physical distancing and hygiene putting
a mask on when you're in an indoor
environment
and a good reminder that if your team
scores you still can't high-five your
friends
unless of course they're in your bubble
mike lacouter global news ottawa
and of course those strict rules for nhl
teams are aimed at keeping both players
and canadians
safe there are now more than 113 000
confirmed cases of covet 19 in canada
nearly 9 000 canadians have died more
than half of those deaths are in quebec
and it has now been six months since
canada identified its first
case of covid19 but as mike draulie
explains health experts are still
debating
the deadliness of the disease here are
the latest numbers
the numbers have been adding up for
months cases
tests deaths a puzzle of information
epidemiologists have used to determine
how deadly covid19 would be even if we
didn't have all the pieces
we won't know the true fatality of this
disease until
it's all said and done part of the
problem is the numbers can be misleading
how is it that belgium has the highest
number of deaths per million in the
world
almost four times out of canada while
india which has the third most cases
has so few deaths it comes down to
reporting
belgium has a robust system in place
while india's
is deeply flawed i mean i think the
comparisons across
countries can be problematic in the
sense that you know nobody wants to be
the worst
performing country and so there there is
potentially
a desire to not necessarily count things
very well and not be the country who has
the most debts
that reality has led to the raw numbers
being interpreted in very different
and politically motivated ways it's a
false narrative
to take comfort in in a lower rate of
death so epidemiologists like to point
to the most accurate tool they have the
ifr or
infection fatality rate which also
considers asymptomatic cases
in january the world health organization
set kovid 19's ifr
at 3.4 percent a century ago the spanish
flu was 2 percent
but with more information covid19's ifr
has decreased to the current estimate of
one percent
which would still make it far deadlier
than the flu a different reality from
what coveted deniers are pushing
people are saying that because they're
blinded by their own ideology
so on its face it's untrue look at the
usa
a bad season of the flu in the usa kills
about 60 000 people that's a really bad
season
they've already had over 130 000 covered
deaths
and it could get worse if the world
fails to treat covet 19
like the deadly disease it is microlight
global news toronto
australia has just suffered its
deadliest day of the pandemic
10 people died in 24 hours in the state
of victoria where new infections are
surging
mainly in melbourne seven of those
deaths are linked to outbreaks in
long-term care homes
and the british government has now
removed spain from the list of safe
places to travel
following another surge in cases and is
warning that citizens who do choose to
travel there
will now be required to self-isolate for
14 days upon their return
and in north korea leader kim jong-un
has declared an emergency
and locked down a border town amid fears
over what could be that country's first
confirmed case of covid 19.
state media is reporting a person
suspected of contracting the virus
returned from south korea
up until now north korea has claimed
that it was virus free
coming up hannah's aftermath how hard
did the first hurricane of the season
hit the lone star state
take a look at this the aftermath of
hannah roaring ashore in southern texas
the category 1 hurricane is now
downgraded
to a tropical depression tracking into
northeastern mexico
but at its peak hannah packed 150
kilometer an hour winds
and sent punishing waves crashing into
the coastline a rescue crew actually had
to pull three people from a sailboat
sinking in a marina
where they'd been trying to ride out the
storm hannah may be weakening but it's
still drenching
everything in its path and could drop as
much as 450 millimeters of rain
in some areas scientists are sounding
the alarm over climate change and polar
bears for the first time a new report
led by canadian researchers
is putting a clear time frame on when
certain polar bear populations are
expected to collapse
redmond shannon has the details
for polar bears sea ice is literally
their platform for seal hunting
when they store up energy for a lean
summer on dry land
but those summer fasts have been getting
longer
and longer making survival more
difficult
first scientific study on polar bears
and climate change was published in 1993
we have known that they will be impacted
the thing that we didn't know
is when they would be impacted but now
we have
a better idea a new study led by
university of toronto researchers
is putting a timeline on polar bear
survival
it says cubs will very likely struggle
to survive in southern hudson bay
within this decade other regions will
follow
soon after and that's under an
intermediate emissions scenario
for a worst worst-case scenario the
report says the demise of polar bears
across almost
all of the arctic will be inevitable by
the end of the century
the results weren't surprising but it is
nonetheless important and and you know i
hope it emphasizes the urgency of the
problem to now
actually be able to put a timeline on
these changes just like we're putting
timelines and sea ice changes and
temperature changes it comes as an
international group of scientists say we
are no longer able to hope for the best
with those temperature changes for four
decades
scientists have said if and when carbon
levels doubled from pre-industrial
levels
the probable range of global warming
would be 1.5 to 4.5 degrees
this new analysis narrows that to
between about 2.6
and about 4.1 degrees basically this
study kind of provides a balanced
opinion like we're not doomed but we
also not
should not be too careless because the
earth is going to warm
in response to emitting co2 to the
atmosphere
anything under 2 degrees is deemed
extremely unlikely
if carbon dioxide doubles levels are
currently
35 above any time since the ice age
when it comes to the future of polar
bears and the planet
these results should only further focus
minds of policy makers
the realities of climate change are
approaching and now we know more than
ever
what they will look like redmond shannon
global news london
still ahead the former republicans
gearing up to take down
donald trump
welcome back in 100 days americans will
head to the polls to choose their next
president and donald trump is dealing
with a growing opposition
hard-hitting ads are springing up online
and on television
from an unlikely source former
republican strategists
eric sorensen has more on the so-called
never
trumpers there's morning in america and
under the leadership of donald trump
our country is weaker and sicker and
poorer
what sounds like a democratic attack ad
is not
paid for by the lincoln project with the
lincoln project
these once high-level republican
operatives spent careers
ambushing democrats but in 2020 have
turned their ruthless
instincts on president trump we fight
very hard
sometimes you might think we fight a
little dirty but something's wrong with
donald trump
he's shaky weak trouble speaking
trouble walking they are doing tougher
ads against trump
than any democratic group they are
brazen
and articulate he has eviscerated the
norms of the american
presidency you sense the betrayal they
feel
job of the president is to protect the
country donald trump has been completely
derelict in his duty
i guess they don't like me but let me
just tell you
these are losers from day one if one aim
of the lincoln project was to needle
donald trump
it worked they should call it the losers
project
they used principal conservative appeals
to
try to denounce trump but i've never i
don't recall seeing anything
quite so overt and organized as i'm
seeing now
and there are others like conservative
thinker bill crystal
an unleashed trump and a second term he
also dreads a trump re-election i do
think that's something
i don't want to see his group republican
voters against trump relies on the power
of raw testimonials from average
republicans
he consistently called the coronavirus a
hoax he's letting over a hundred
thousand people die due to his
incompetence
josh from north carolina voted for trump
four years ago
not my proudest moment i will not be
voting for him again
having voters in their own voice
speak directly to the camera about why
they've changed their mind
and letting other voters know that it's
okay to do so those are
powerful narratives but will this
campaign change the minds of staunch
trump supporters
they're certainly not going to persuade
that face to
change their voting behavior but at the
margins
it might matter a lot and right now
american politics and elections aren't
you know decided by
slim margins learn their names
with donations flooding in the lincoln
project has now turned its sights on
republican senators
and never ever trust them
again their expanded aim to remove from
power completely donald trump
and the party they once embraced eric
sorensen global news
still ahead why a canadian celebrity is
joining the desperate search for this
beloved bear
welcome back this isn't just any
ordinary teddy bear it holds some of the
precious last words spoken by a mother
to her daughter
and now it's gone missing mara soriano's
mother marilyn
passed away from cancer last summer but
before her death marilyn recorded
this message
as you can see she put the recording in
a custom made teddy bear as a gift but
while mara was moving to her apartment
in vancouver last week
the bag containing the cherished toy was
stolen
now she's pleading for its return
the five minutes that i put it down and
he unloaded the back of the
uhaul this person had come in and
taken the bag she says mara i love you
i'm so proud of you i'll always be with
you
and every time i missed her i would hug
that bear and i would listen to that
recording
but soriano is now getting some
hollywood help her plight caught the
attention of vancouver-born celebrity
ryan reynolds who tweeted saturday that
he'll give five
thousand dollars to anyone who returns
the bear tomorrow
zero questions asked here's hoping for a
happy ending
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm jeff semple tonight's your
canada
is little boshking lake in ontario
thanks for watching we'll see you back
here again tomorrow
have a great night
you